[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
yes happy Wednesday happy Wednesday
everyone what a great show we have
tonight I'm so excited Jared Kushner has
joined us this evening
if you look close see the regrets
starting to take shape on his face
and for some reason we welcome back Mike
Baker
let's let's hope he can complete a
sentence using only 50 ohms and 24
groans
[Music]
yes Mike Baker when you need a coherent
thought in 24 hours don't call him
all right so ever since Joe Biden's
speech from the innermost circle of hell
I've been thinking a lot about the
future of this country he warned us of a
terrible threat and no not that he ate
fiber before boarding the roller coaster
at Six Flags it's the extreme Maga
Republican who apparently number in the
dozens
or perhaps Millions we really never get
a head count on the threat we're not
even sure they have heads
but the vagueness of the threat
certainly is convenient mainly because
it's hard to count something that
doesn't really exist unless unlike say
the persisted and violent crime we now
experience every single day across this
country
oddly none of that is caused by people
in Red Hats fact is Extreme Maga aren't
like sheep you can't count them to fall
asleep because there's really not enough
of them and for a Democrat it's best
never to know how truly big the threat
is or it might actually end up going
away fact is Trump supporters are the
new climate change we can't quantify it
but we can tell you it's evil but the
fear tactic it's effective thanks to Joe
and the media we now have a democratic
majority in a poll who believe that
Trump supporters are a serious threat to
democracy hell they even got 25 percent
of Republicans to agree but let's be
honest those are the really dumb ones
when those two heard 25 they thought all
right our best approval numbers ever
and of course you have the Democrats
pushing the idea that violence is
looming around the corner here's Eric
swalwell in between bouts of rampant
farting and having sex with Chinese
spies talking about the coming wave of
violent Republicans
they are so out of alignment with
mainstream America where they can't win
the majority of votes in elections that
they now are more comfortable with
violence than voting because that's
their only path to enacting their
political agenda
remember when that guy ran for president
yeah neither can he I I think he pulled
lower than Kamala Harris which is like
saying you pulled lower than anal warts
no offense to people with anal warts
it's a common problem
Mike
[Laughter]
yes nothing that ointment can't clear up
yeah it's true
so I decided to do some research about
this Maga threat I know I know as a big
star I shouldn't have to do that but it
was either that or bare knuckle boxing
with Dagan McDowell in her office
besides my intern was busy with my
laundry kill meat is such a heavy
bleeder
since Joe in the media never ever named
the actual threats referring to it to be
an amorphous Anonymous blob like
man-made climate change or joy behar's
body odor
I wanted to see if I could put a name to
this demon perhaps it's one of these
Republican candidates running for office
after all all they ever talk about is
pornography
find what pornographic needs for you in
terms of books in case do you you need
me to Define pornographic I mean I can
if you want me to all right so there's
there's two naked people and they are
acting out a sexual act so in multiple
different sexual acts
do you want me to send you some so you
can see them that would be fine because
I feel like it's going to be a little
awkward
to show you
I love her
I really love her why did she stop
honestly I kind of wish she'd kept going
I was just getting into it
I was moments away from whipping out my
credit card a credit card let's see
Gretchen Whitmer match that kind of
pillow talk but then again maybe not the
FBI might try to kidnap her again
[Music]
so yeah it's kinky and all but is it a
threat to democracy unless by democracy
you mean my pants
however that's terrible however I think
I finally found the threat to this great
Republic her name is Linda Paulson I'm
sure you agree she is a monster a Utah
District 12 you better listen up right
here because that's a new name on the
ballot for the state senate this year
hey Utah District 12. listen up right
here there's a new name on the ballot
for the Senate this year my name is
Linda Paulson Republican and awesome
love God and family and the Constitution
I try to get another conservative to
rent nobody could do it so I'm getting
it done
all right
she's rapping and she's adorable and if
she's smoking any weed it's definitely
medicinal
but damn it Linda I wonder if you were
pro-religious freed and pro-life and
pro-police I'm probably probably live
this free that pro-life Pro police the
right to bear arms and the right to
freeze feed I want less government
control and regulation want to stop and
expose all political corruption where's
Integrity morality accountability
government programs should lead to
self-sufficiency and support traditional
family as the fundamental unit of
society but in schools they are pushing
for new beliefs and just to clarify this
because there's some who can Define this
as a female adult I know what a woman is
thank you
yes he knows what a woman is quick
someone introduced her to katanji Brown
Jackson
but no wonder she's dangerous she thinks
there's two biological Sexes I hope the
doj the FBI and the IRS have her on
their list and not for overusing the
AARP discount
because I wonder if she loves loves this
country I love this country it's a
blessing to be free but Freedom comes
with responsibility the Constitution
needs to be protected not change or
disregarded but resurrected if you share
my values if you like what I stand for
then give me your fold on the 8th of
November District 12 needs a choice let
me be your voice Linda Paulson Linda
Paulson for Senate so
Linda Paulson for Senate now there's a
real threat to democracy she's Joe
McCarthy in drag which probably means
she's a decent person a nice lady and
should be elected because currently
nobody fits that description who works
in DC you could call her the Bizarro
Hillary Clinton
and I would vote for her but I'm not a
citizen of Utah and I'm not allowed
after that incident with the Mormon
Tabernacle backer choir
Mormon Tabernacle Choir
that's the last time I inquire about a
missionary position
the Republican Party no wonder the Dems
are scared a senior citizen who likes to
rap hey I think I just described Brett
Bear
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
somewhere somewhere Vanilla Ice is
rolling in his grave
[Applause]
tonight's yes he brought Democrats brief
by bringing peace to the Middle East
former senior adviser to president Trump
and author of the number one book
breaking history Jared Kushner
[Applause]
he does his best work undercover and
under the covers former CIA operative
and host of black files Declassified on
Discovery Science Channel Mike Baker
she's like a beanie baby cute but we all
thought she'd be worth more money by now
trivia cat tip
and fortune tellers call his palms War
and Peace because they take forever to
read
I know my massive sidekick in the NWA
World Television Champion Tyrus
Jared congratulations number one on the
New York Times bestseller list I'm back
there thrilled they really enjoyed
putting it there I can imagine yeah
there is one flop I checked the index
I'm not mentioned in this book at all I
think that was the first version you
were in but it must have gotten cut so
we apologize for it would you please put
it back in I expect an entire chapter on
how I influence the administration what
do you uh how do you do you feel like
you are a threat to the Democracy
because you're part of the Trump World
according to what I hear sometimes I do
think they are you know I think what the
people in Washington didn't understand
about Trump voters is that they wanted
things like low gas prices low taxes
they wanted peace in the world they
don't want to have wars in Ukraine or
you know China being provocative and
that was really why I wrote the book I
want people to understand all the things
that happened during the Trump
Administration despite all the craziness
you would constantly see in the Press
whether it was accusing us you saw Eric
swallow earlier of accusing us of
colluding with Russia for two years
which turned out we did include with
Russia we won a campaign and so you had
all these different currents that we
wanted to cover and that's uh what when
I traveled the country I saw Trump
voters were just good people who wanted
their country restored in the way that
they wanted to live and so that was what
I tried to portray that's what I liked
about your book is that you basically
you weren't part of this world you were
kind of forced through marriage you were
probably just a Basics typical New York
liberal well I'll put that in but you
had to change you had to go out you had
to look you had to hang out with these
people and you turn out wow this thing's
real these are real people and I thought
that was interesting I I'm gonna piss
off so many people but I thought that
this book is the best book about the
administration and I think that will
probably upset a few people that are
come on this show just because like you
were telling you you explained behind
the scenes of a lot of stuff that I like
you know I wanted it like the middle the
middle east peace process you knew
nothing about this you didn't even know
you were going to work on it you didn't
know it and then you go and you do it
and you succeed because you're not a
diplomat you actually succeeded because
you're not a DC Diplomat anyway I'm
blowing too much smoke up your ass well
what I will say well first of all thank
you you could do more of that if you'd
like maybe I should just be quiet and
let you go but but I will say that I
think that what was very important for
me to portray to people was that I
wasn't a New York liberal I think I was
somebody who's a pragmatist and I think
that we have all the titles today but I
really show what it was like to travel
through the country explore meet people
have an open mind and learn about things
like the Middle East learn about things
like what the policies were that people
wanted and then see how president Trump
and his administration delivered those
things yeah so while you were helping
people Mike Baker you were killing them
only only the ones that weren't helping
yes exactly that's all right you only
kill the bad people Mike is that what
you do uh what would you like to comment
on how about uh Miss Paulson I mean
corny but really good yeah um I mean
first of all if I might say your work on
the Middle East uh policies uh well done
uh didn't get enough appreciation or
attention
in the green room if I may
that was between you and me
second uh as far as tutor Dixon goes
um and since we're at this pornography
only involved two people
and no llama I mean what what kind of
porn is she watching
but yeah and as far as Linda Paulson
goes God bless her um she kind of
reminds me of of my mom in a way yeah
you know rest her soul but uh if you're
a white person and you decide to turn
your campaign ad into a rap video then
be prepared to get kicked in the ass
right on social media which is what
happened and then move on fine I think
hey it's it's fun honestly you know I
don't think we're going to see a lot of
these from her so that's a safe
prediction Mike she's a one-hit wonder
yeah yeah she is he is how about you Kat
what did you make of her performance
yeah I just feel like if you're gonna do
a rap you should ask yourself first is
my name Linda
then if if it is you got to be prepared
that maybe the reaction is going to be
mixed
um it was cringe-worthy and of course I
say this as somebody who like I don't
have enough Rhythm for the choreography
in a soul cycle class and that's not so
much a joke as something I had to learn
the hard way
but like she didn't really seem to be
trying no like she would clearly
recorded that one time with no thought
of Rhythm or Cadence or anything else I
can't believe you're seriously
criticizing this I was more critical of
the music I thought the music was not as
good as her voice I
likely an over emphasization of how much
I care
again recreationally oh yeah I'm gonna
have it on repeat all night Tyrus in the
hot tub you know what I'm saying no no
I I loved it yeah and I and I what I
loved the most about it uh because we
seem to forget and the this is where the
the media always kind of tells on
themselves the first thing that you
heard from all these media experts the
left side was how she wasn't black and I
found like wow man that's a really
racist thing to say that an art form
can't be expressed by anyone yeah sure
Rhythm was off you know what but her
heart was in it and I listened to the
whole thing because I was laughing and
put a smile on my face and that's kind
of the whole point of what rap is and I
guess no one ever heard of Eminem yeah
or the Beastie Boys you know what I'm
saying it's an art form he left out
Vanilla Ice well vanilla always left
himself out
R.I.P by the way yeah but he's still
alive got felt
and probably waiting for you in the
parking lot yes
somebody does some does something out
the box and the first thing that the
left does is they remind us all that
like whoa only black people can do that
says who like good for her Linda proved
it yeah no but hey
you ride bryman Constitution is hard for
anybody exactly okay and she did it and
you know what I know exactly where she
stands on everything you find another
politician right now where you know
exactly where they stand they should all
be you know it we all know where she
stands where she's about how happy she
is both her hips work yeah like she had
a lot of things going on good for her
yeah I hope she does another one
excellent point you know what uh when I
host the fox debate in 2024 which I I
haven't told anybody yet I'm gonna make
all I am hosting the fox debate film
drop 16 bars go what do you got oh no no
I'm gonna have all the candidates wrap
their uh rap there that's what 14 bars
means gut felt oh geez such a boomer you
want to criticize her and you even know
the language
that's not what I meant rap
oh just seems to me you're getting your
ass kicked here yeah yeah oh go back to
Idaho okay hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else